[تصفيق]
في اول زياره خارجيه له بعد اعاده انتخابه
رئيسا للبلاد لولايه ثالثه يتوجه الرئيس
الصيني الى موسكو للقاء الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين الزياره التي يتوقع ان
تثير كثيرا من الترقب في العواصم الغربيه
ستركز بحسب مصادر رسميه صينيه وروسيه على
التعاون العسكري والتقني والاقتصادي
وقضايا الطاقه اضافه بالطبع الى ملف الحرب
في اوكرانيا لاسيما وان القمه المنتظره
تاتي بعد اقل من شهر على تقديم بيجين
مبادره لحل الازمه هناك وفي حين اكد مساعد
الرئيس الروسي ان بلاده تثمن عاليا ما
وصفه بالموقف المتوازن للقياده الصينيه من
النزاع في اوكرانيا وبانه يتوافق الى حد
كبير والرؤيه الروسيه فان ذلك لم يحل دون
اعلان كييف انفتاحها على دور صيني اذ اعلن
وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني ديمت ان هناك مع
نظيره الصيني تشينجان المبادئ التي يمكن
على اساسها استعاده السلام في اوكرانيا مع
التجديد على مبدا وحده اراضي البلاد ورغم
ان الحلفاء الغربيين لكييف وفي مقدمتهم
الولايات المتحده سبق ان شككوا بالمبادره
الصينيه على اعتبار ان بيجين ومهما حاولت
ان تلعب دورا محايدا ستبقى اقرب لروسيا من
اوكرانيا فان ذلك لم يحل دون تشجيع خجول
من البيت الابيض للصين لكي تنفتح اكثر على
وجهه النظر الاوكرانيه اذ نقلت شبكه السي
ان ان عن مسؤولين امريكيين عزمهم على
ترتيب اتصال بين رئيس الصيني ونظيره
الاوكراني وايا يكن رهان الامريكي على هذه
الخطوه ومدى قدرتها على احداث تغيير جوهري
بموقف بيجين من كييف فان القلق الاكبر
لديها يبقى دائما من تقديم الصين لاي دعم
عسك لروسيا اذ اكد منسق الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي جون كيربي ان العلاقات بين بيجين
وموسكو تعمقت بشكل كبير منذ اندلاع الحرب
وان كانت لا توجد ادلات حتى الان على
استخدام اسلحه صينيه في ساحه المعارك
وكانت الخارجيه الصينيه قد اكدت ان بيجين
طالما تبنت موقفا مسؤولا تجاه تصدير
المعدات العسكريه وان شددت على ان التعاون
الصيني الروسي يتمتع بامكانيات هائله
ومرونه قويه وان البلدين قدما نموذجا
جديدا للعلاقات الدوليه